[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans ce
nouveau numéro du 7-8 culture
aujourd'hui nous sommes à la clé des
champs à plaisir pour le nouveau
festival des escales urbaines mais avant
cela voici le sommaire la ville de
plaisir organise son premier festival
les escales urbaines propose des
concerts des ateliers et même du sport
nous parlerons de la programmation avec
le directeur de la clé des champs ce
week-end dernier les 20 et 21 novembre à
versailles le salon histoire de lire
avait lieu dans différents endroits de
la ville au programme débats conférences
et dédicaces d'auteurs et puis enfin la
roue des comptes revient pour une
seizième édition à la celle saint cloud
le pays mise en avant cette année la
syrie
[Musique]
je me trouve dans la salle de concert de
la clé des champs à plaisir un nouveau
festival est organisé par la ville ils
s'appellent les escales urbaines et
proposera de nombreux concerts et
animations jusqu'au 27 novembre frédéric
poletto bonjour bonjour vous êtes le
directeur de la clé des champs alors est
ce que peut-être vous pouvez me
présenter ce tout nouveau festival alors
c'est un festival qui se déroule du 17
au 22 novembre
dans la salle de la clé des champs avec
trois soirées concerts un festival
consacré aux cultures urbaines trois
soirées concerts des résidences et des
actions culturelles durant deux semaines
alors qu'elle est la programmation est
ce que pouvait alors nous recevons
deux groupes en résidence le bénin
international musicale et le groupe sex
machine de cette semaine
et nous avons déjà eu deux concerts avec
une première soirée avec le bim et bâtir
at centre la partie puis une soirée plus
hip hop avec tracy de sa catégorie
qu'est jr
voilà donc trois grosses soirées
concerts et des actions culturelles en
direction de différents publics
collégiens de la ville de plaisir
hôpital maison des ados et le
conservatoire oui donc beaucoup beaucoup
de choses c'est très varié c'est sans
fils avec des ateliers danse percussions
master classes ateliers d'écriture
atelier rap avec tracy de ça voilà tout
plein de choses ce festival c'est d'être
aussi l'occasion pour bien les
compagnies d'être en résidence ici c'est
cela c'est à la fois un travail d'action
culturelle et
un travail scénique pour les deux
groupes qui sont en résidence le bim
préparer également un concert pour radio
france ce lundi
voilà et surtout c'est une façon de
créer du lien avec de nouveaux publics
autour de ces pratiques là lors de ce
festival il ya aussi beaucoup d'ateliers
comme celui donc de tracy de ça un
atelier rap proposé par cette rappeuse
ok ça c'est la base maintenant essayer d
variés à nos 3 à 4 1 2 3 4 1 2 3 4 5 et
6 1 2 3 4 5 et 6 et un 2e le flou un
élément important dans le rap le rythme
la façon dont on prononce les mots dans
une chanson la rappeuse tracy de sa
animé cet atelier rap pour les enfants
dans le cadre du festival des escales
urbaines à plaisir est ce que je vais
faire c'est d'essayer d'activer le
vocabulaire passive des gens on l'a tous
eu plein de mots dans nos têtes qui sont
gardés au fond et qu'on n'utilise pas au
quotidien donc là le but ça va être
d'aller chercher ce vocabulaire pour
pouvoir le mettre à après dans les
textes pouvoir faire des punchline des
jeux de mots et après je vais faire un
travail sur la musicalité sur la
musicalité sur le compte apprendre à
bien compter la musique pour cela la
rappeuse propose des petits exercices
pour apprendre à créer des variations et
des interprétations différentes par
exemple ce jeu de rim les enfants
doivent se faire des passes passe de
mots qui riment le but réfléchir vite
pour pouvoir en profiter il ajouté zaz
éthique avec l'équipe hommage aux dix
pour les declik vase et un autre enfant
un petit jeu au monde à dire des rimes
est fliqué bas et si une réforme 10
secondes ni éliminé simplet mais
quelquefois ces tirs elle essaie de nous
apprendre un peu ce qu'a fait dans la
musique et elle nous fédérer des travaux
sur des rimes et cetera tous à leur
façon de s'exprimer écrire des petits
textes et apprendre à poser sa voix le
rap est donc accessible pour les enfants
objectif transmettre des idées à travers
les textes
alors frédéric paul et on vient de voir
le sujet hormis bien sûr les concerts et
les activités prévues mais aussi des
actions culturelles en vous disais mené
auprès des élèves pays roi c'est ça
c'est ça notamment semaine avec le
groupe sax machine
qui intervient sur le collège blaise
pascal avec des ateliers d'écriture en
français anglais avec les m6 du groupe
un atelier de musique assistée par
ordinateur
et des master class avec le
conservatoire de plaisir ce mercredi et
ce jeudi très bien et a finalement ce
festival c'est aussi l'occasion
peut-être de mettre en avant la culture
mais aussi le sport c'est ça il ya une
tournoi durban de foot qui clôturera la
manifestation samedi à plaisir présent
et ss fini avec un concert aussi le
dernier concert c'est vendredi soir avec
sex machine
super merci beaucoup
le salon histoire de lire à versailles
c'était ce week-end les 20 et 21
novembre cet événement phare de la ville
met en lumière l'histoire cette science
du maine accessible à tous pour sa 14e
édition des débats des conférences
encore des rencontres avec des auteurs
étaient proposés regard des
conférences débats ou encore séances de
dédicaces après une édition virtuelle
l'année dernière auteur comme
participants sont heureux de se
retrouver au salon histoire de lire qui
se déroulait cette année dans quatre
lieux emblématiques de versailles je
viens chaque année parce que
l'histoire m'intéresse énormément je lis
beaucoup de livres d'histoire et c'est
intéressant de pouvoir rencontrer les
auteurs et de voir l'actualité des
publications des auteurs que je connais
que j'ai envie de rencontrer et puis que
je revois régulièrement d'ailleurs qui
viennent tous les ans et puis c'est
l'occasion aussi de découvrir des livres
que voilà par par surprise ce retour à
la fois grâce à l'écriture voire d'avoir
des retours de lecteurs et puis deux et
puis sur les planches en même temps suit
non je passe une rentrée très belle le
salon histoire de lire c'est une
manifestation qui a lieu depuis une
quinzaine d'années à versailles dans la
mairie dans la l'hôtel du département la
préfecture dans plusieurs lieux de la
ville et s'y rassemblent environ 150 180
auteurs avec un point commun qui est
l'histoire lecteurs passionnés ou
simples curieux le salon s'est attiré un
large public du roman historique à la
bande dessinée en passant par l'essai et
même la présentation de jeux de société
il y en a pour tous les goûts réseau
permet de s'approprier l'histoire de la
résistance de ses actions et des dangers
rencontrés par les résistants dans
toutes les opérations qu'ils ont pu
mener sur le territoire de l'ancienne
seynoise ce qui est amusant c'est que je
rencontre d'anciens étudiants des
parents dont six aux étudiants mais
aussi
des passionnés d'histoire pour cette 14e
édition des habitués du salon mais aussi
de nouveaux visages des comédiens
amoureux d'histoire se sont invités au
salon bruno solo francis huster ou
encore philippe torreton ont pu mettre
en scène des écrits d'histoire c'est
l'histoire d'un jeune homme jean
fournier qui qui
qui va mettre beaucoup de temps à mettre
la guerre de 14 enfin derrière lui et à
pouvoir retrouver une certaine raison de
vivre justement ça versailles les
auteurs le disent les lecteurs sont
heureux de discuter d'un sujet d'un
livre avec avec l'auteur et ensuite de
repartir avec une dédicace un salon qui
a récompensé trois youtuber d'histoire
en amont pour la quatrième année de quoi
se mettre à la page pour un salon qui
entend toucher un public encore plus
jeune dans les années à venir
pour un sourire d'enfant est une
association qui agit depuis 25 ans pour
tenter de sauver des enfants des rues et
de la misère au cambodge fondatrice de
l'association marie france d'epire a
écrit un livre qui porte le même nom que
cette association pour un sourire
d'enfant elle était en dédicace à la
librairie des lacs au vésinet
25 ans d'une association résumer en
quatre cents pages pour un sourire
d'enfant raconte l'histoire de cette
association humanitaire fondée par un
couple marie france et christian des
pallières tout jeune retraité ils se
rendent au cambodge à phnom penh en 1995
là bas ils découvrent une décharge à
ciel ouvert où des centaines d'enfants y
travaille on s'est dit voilà on peut pas
laisser ça il faut faire quelque chose
on a commencé petit à petit un pas
devant l'autre sans savoir où
vous auriez dit à cette époque là on en
serait aujourd'hui je me dis attendez
vous êtes fous on a en fait c'est de
répondre aux besoins au fur et à mesure
qu'ils se présentaient tout bêtement
marie-france des pallières a donc voulu
coucher par écrit ses mémoires
elle était en dédicace à la librairie
des lacs au vésinet l'association compte
désormais quatre écoles qui regroupe
vente et une formation six mille cinq
cents enfants qui sont scolarisés dans
les programmes et 5500 enfants qui ont
pu trouver un métier l'engagement est un
aux formes épique auquel on tient qui
est de les accompagner jusqu'à un métier
et donc ça passe par rattrapage scolaire
pour ceux qui ont trois quatre cinq
années de retard ceux qui n'ont pas trop
de retard et sur ce que le réseau en
écoles publiques ont fourni aux familles
de quoi compenser le manque à gagner de
ce que nous en rapporte plus en
travaillant la fondatrice de
l'association restera six mois en france
l'occasion de découvrir ses lecteurs qui
sont généralement aussi donateurs de
l'association que
ces prêts
oui c'est très émouvant et de rencontrer
tout ce qu'on a vu là bas ici enfin qui
ont fait des choses qui nous suivent sur
mercredi 8 décembre marie france des
pallières sera en dédicace à la
librairie gibert joseph à versailles
c'est la 16e édition de la route des
comptes à la celle-saint-cloud pendant
deux mois jusqu'au 12 décembre la ville
organise des conférences des ateliers ou
encore des expositions
cette année le pays mise à l'honneur la
syrie entre photos objets vêtements ou
encore peinture le salon d'exposition de
la mairie de la celle saint cloud est
entièrement refaits aux couleurs de la
syrie une exposition authentique aux
senteurs du savon d'alep et des épices
du pays on a aussi bien un savoir faire
artisanal on va essayer de souligner le
travail qui est fait par les mains une
dimension très historique importante
surtout en ce moment on a besoin de
recontextualiser un petit peu l'histoire
de la syrie et ce qui en a fait l'idée
que c'est vraiment un millefeuille
finalement de plein de choses de plein
d'événements et de pleins de
civilisation qui ont laissé peu à peu
des tracés ont construit la syrie
d'aujourd'hui parmi les artistes
symbolique de l'exposition phadia ziggy
un artiste engagé qui vit et travaille à
damas son oeuvre des dessins de premier
abord naïf mais qui représente des
hommes blessés c'est un soutien qu'ils
apportent au peuple libanais en
représentant l'explosion de beyrouth
qu'il y a eu en 2020 c'est montrer la
solidarité entre les pays notamment
entre le liban et la syrie qui sont très
forts ils ont des liens très puissant
toujours avec l'idée de partager l'art
d'utiliser ce médium artistique pour
s'engager pour aussi montré du
militantisme et soutenir les peuples une
seconde exposition est en place à la mjc
de la celle-saint-cloud des caricatures
du dessinateur annie abbas d'autres
événements plus ponctuelles sont prévues
le 4 et 5 décembre je vous invite
également à venir participer au marché
de noël dans laquelle seront mis en
vente certains produits ici présents
dans des segments dellape le livre
passionnant qui nous fait voyager en
syrie
nuit l'appui de la nuit de la piste
d'une web l'événement se terminera le 12
décembre avec au salon d'exposition des
contrées cité par la comédienne et
auteur alil gay para
et c'est la fin de ce statut de culture
merci de nous avoir suivis rendez vous
la semaine prochaine dans un autre lieu
culturel yvelinois bonne soirée sur tv
[Musique]